des perquisitions t'étais menées ce
matin dans le dossier du fond Marianne à
la fois au domicile du préfet Christian
Gravel ex responsable de la gestion de
ce fond et de Mohammed Sifaoui principal
bénéficiaire émissionné des missionné
séances tenantes permettez-vous de
croire un instant que le mot de
responsabilité peut avoir du sens pour
un membre du gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la formation judiciaire a
été ouverte début mai pour des soupçons
de détournement de fonds publics par
négligence d'abus de confiance et de
prise illégale d'intérêt dans un état de
droit c'est la justice
qui connaît ni
le traité
et la justice et la justice vous le
savez tous la justice a pris en main ce
dossier une altercation entre un
cycliste et un taxi à Paris rien de très
original mais quelques mètres plus loin
les deux hommes en viennent presque
commun quand une femme en veste bleue
interview
cette vidéo issue d'un live sur twitch
est devenu viral plus de 2,6 millions de
vues le calme a fini par revenir et
l'élu en a profité pour faire un peu de
politique en demandant plus de pistes
cyclables nous vous donnons notre accord
pour le copier coller vous pourriez
ainsi vous attaquer aux droits du sol et
à la délinquance en expulsant les
délinquants étrangers réformer l'ame
réformer le droit d'asile bref vous
pourriez avec le projet de Marine Le Pen
répondre aux attentes légitimes des
Français et tourner la page du manque de
courage politique Emmanuel Macron avait
fait la promesse une cinquantaine de
médicaments essentiels vont voir leur
production relocaliser en France annonce
faite par le chef de l'État lors d'un
déplacement en Ardèche objectif et bien
faire face aux pénuries traversées
récemment d'ailleurs les victimes ne
vous intéressent pas vous n'avez pas un
mot pour les enfants ce n'est pas un mot
pour les parents pendant cette question
d'actualité
finalement l'histoire ne se déroule pas
comme l'imagine Madame Le Pen et tout le
rassemblement national et je peux vous
dire que c'est le dégoût qui nous
inspire quand vous parlez de ce sujet
sur la cinquantaine de premiers
médicament essentiels pour lesquels
notre dépendance aux importations
extra-européennes est avérée donc les
médicaments à relocaliser et bien la
moitié c'est à dire 25 de ces
médicaments verront leur production
relocalisée ou augmenter
significativement sur le territoire
national une mère de poisson mort sur
les plages du Texas des milliers
d'animaux marins ont été retrouvés
échoués entassés les uns sur les autres
fleurs est à l'émotion naturellement
l'enquête doit permettre de faire toute
la lumière toute la lumière sur le
parcours de cette agresseur toute la
lumière sur ses motivations mais ne
mélangeons pas tout ne récupérons pas
des drames épouvantables comme ceux que
nous avons vécu en cause un manque
d'oxygène dans l'eau dû à une
température trop élevée
c'est ce que l'on appelle de l'hypoxie
s'il fallait un symptôme de la bêtise de
l'époque s'il fallait un indice de la
lâcheté du moment l'écriture inclusive
illustre la démission des gouvernants
comme la peur la soumission ou la
faiblesse de toutes nos institutions les
promoteurs de cannois Island jettent
l'éponge cette plage flottante privée
dont nous vous avions parlé dans nos
précédentes éditions espérait jeter
l'encre sur la Côte d'Azur faute
d'obtenir les permis nécessaire les
concepteurs renoncent donc au projet
donc on écrit misix maman
Nouvel An c'est la scène qui suscite la
stupéfaction en Équateur au cours de
cette veillée funéraire cette femme
vient de donner des signes de vie
elle avait été déclarée morte à
l'hôpital elle était dans ce cercueil
depuis 12 heures et on se rend compte
qu'elle est en vie chenille par toujours
à l'heure
[Musique]
style d'hier a commencé à tortiller à
18h et il n'a pas fallu beaucoup de
temps aux Normands pour battre le record
3940 participants soit la chenille la
plus longue du monde elle avait été
admise suite à un AVC une erreur de
diagnostic les pompiers arrivent pour
prendre la vieille dame agonisante mais
en vie de nouveau admis à l'hôpital elle
a été placé sous oxygène et son cœur est
stable